it was almost like Carnival the Portilla
Samba School in Rio de Janeiro was the
latest stop for presidential candidate
luisi nasso Lula da Silva campaigning
for another crack at the presidency
not that his supporters needed much
convincing
thousands of mostly low-income
Brazilians were nearly crushed trying to
get a glimpse of the candidate using
their fingers to make the letter L for
Lula others were moved to tears when
Lula spoke of how he too knew what it
was like to grow up in abject poverty
I just want to be president to take care
of my people because I know what people
want they want a house no matter how
small to Shelter From the rain and the
sun they want a job with a fair salary
the biggest dream of many women here is
not to leave their children a fortune
but rather a profession so they can rest
in peace and go to heaven
although Lula is leading in the polls he
warned the enthusiastic crowd that
former U.S presidential candidate
Hillary Clinton lost the election
because too many Americans stayed home
instead of voting Luna compared himself
to Gandhi and Mandela whom he said like
himself had been unfairly imprisoned but
eventually got out to free their country
but unlike Gandhi and Mandela charges
that he had overseen the largest
corruption scandal in Brazilian history
while he was President billions and
billions of dollars continue to weigh
heavily on Lula but people like Juliana
believe his virtues are more important
than his faults
it was Lula's government that gave
people opportunities like the chance for
the poorest sector of society to go to
university I simply cannot defend the
current president's policies that's why
we need Lula
this campaign event took place in what
is supposed to be the stronghold of his
rival Jade bolsonaro who is fighting for
a second term as president that Lula is
even running it all is something that
would have seemed Unthinkable four years
ago when he was sent to prison on
corruption charges something he always
denied
but then he always promised he would be
back
Lucia Newman Al Jazeera Rio de Janeiro